if you have an opportunity to see  bloodshot anti-vaccination with the  technology in your veins you have an  army inside you that it scores a big  adventurous action film which obviously  been sort of just naturally embodies but  there's a wonderful like vulnerability  to the character who's being manipulated  through technology which I feel is  something like we all face today there's  a richness to this storyline that I  think will continue to shock people for  a long time control about that the big  action scenes I still want to experience  in an IMAX it's a large bombastic action  adventure which will play even better on  that giant screen I  [Music]